folks how we doing thanks for stopping
by today we are going to talk about a
common question that I'm asked enough to
make this video so we're looking at a
small area however you can replicate
this times as big of an area as you have
to do the question of the day is how do
you level out a bumpy lawn a bumpy field
a bumpy
pasture how do you level these areas out
well the biggest challenge with these
areas that you're going to deal with is
size all right or maybe it's weeds
inside or it's all that organic matter
that's on the surface that's rooted in
there all right and most customers when
they reach out to me they're looking for
a tool or tools to
accomplish this
renovation the first thing that they
mention is using a box blade or a lamp
plane and if you have sad those are not
going to be the right tools to use they
are very challenging because of the root
systems and if you have the scarifiers
or the shanks that are on those tools
you may think I can rip through that
surface rip it all up and then just use
the box blade or the plane just to kind
of pull it all to the side but what
you're going to find is it's just
creating a huge mess those Shanks are
going to rip through the ground every 6
8 10 Ines apart you're going to have to
drive back and forth over and over and
over again to get all of the different
root clumps worked up and then you're
going to have to drive all over it again
over and over and over and over again to
repeatedly collect all that material
you're going to wind up with a gigantic
pile of it or multiple piles of it
scattered all about that you have to
then clean up with a bucket it's just
going to be a long arduous tedious
process that's not going to give you
great results on top of that you're
stripping away a lot of good organic
material that should be there to help
Reed your pasture your lawn whatever it
is basically those nutrients that you
would want to have in the soil to begin
with to help give it a good start what I
have found and we've done this actually
in in many different scenarios we've
we've used tillers okay we've used a
tiller right here and if you follow the
channel this area was actually littered
with stumps just like this
one there's one that's just off to the
side a little bit an area that we
haven't renovated but stumps just like
this one this whole area was full of
them and we used our stump wer we dug
all those out and made a big old mess
okay there were holes here and piles of
dirt around and then the stumps of
course that we got out of there but then
we just kind of used our bucket and
pushed the dirt back in those those
holes where the stumps were at just to
get it kind of a a rough level then we
came back through with a tiller and we
tilled this whole area all right we
didn't till just the areas that had the
bumps we just tilled everything so that
it worked the entire surface up
consistently right and we did that two
or three times just back and forth back
and forth back and forth and so what
that's going to do is it's going to
break up consistently all the side
clumps here it doesn't mean it's going
to get rid of every single last one and
break it down into a super fine matter
but it's doing it repeatedly across the
whole area so it's smooth and consistent
and you can work with it and the great
part is it leaves all that organic
matter right there it's right there
where it needs to be where it's going to
do its best work helping to regrow the
grass or um The Orchard grasses or
whatever it is that you're planning in
that area that you want to succeed and
so we did most of this work last spring
okay we dug out the stumps I tilled
everything up and then I used a deer
rake you could also use a landscape rake
if you had that on hand or depending on
what your long-term application is you
want a tool that's versatile a landscape
rake or a dethatcher either one is super
versatile and this is just one
application for it but I took the decher
and raked everything to one side so
there was still some you know little
side clumps and there are some sticks
and some other little bits of debris in
here rake those all to one side it was a
lot less material and and the
rakes and the deers they're going to let
the dirt kind of fall out for the most
part you're just stuck with the debris
that you don't want there so it's still
leaving a lot of the nutrients there as
well got what you see here okay and then
of course what happened well we had no
rain all right I kept waiting for there
to be rain in the forecast to seed this
area and we had a super dry Spring and
most of the summer as well and so I
didn't do anything I didn't put any seed
down to that point because it wasn't
going to be successful and there were
some weeds that were growing up here and
there and so what I did is when I came
back in the fall when I was planting
food plots I repeated that process I
tilted up one more time okay which was
really easy to do because i' previously
tilled it then I came back through and
used the Thatcher EG one more time just
to get a nice final level right cuz that
rake whether it's the Thatcher or the
landscape rake is one long plane right
it's at the same level and so you can
get a 5 foot or a 6ot or an 8ot whatever
size rake you want to get one grade okay
so it makes it much more consistent back
and forth to be a level surface at that
point I seated I used our Beth Co seater
broadcast seated this area and then I
use my rake one more time to kind of
help cover all that seed up and give it
the best possible chance for germination
did that in it was either late August or
early September actually that's not true
it was late September I got to it a
little bit late and so this is what you
see going on and so it the grass the
seedlings all got a good start for now
had about maybe a month or so of uh
decent growing conditions in the fall
and this will be great next spring and
in fact we actually had sprinklers put
in down in this area here so we'll be
able to irrigate this water this on a
regular basis and uh and maintain it
just like part of our yard but the same
concept the same process can be applied
to whether it's a little just a little
patch here that's what 40 by 80 ft or if
you're doing a two or three acre
renovation you don't have to do the
whole thing at one time you can still
break it down into chunks maybe a
quarter here and a quarter there maybe
get your process down right do a smaller
area the first time see if you're doing
everything in the right order the right
sequence that you want to do and then
just repeat that on the rest of it and
it it can make it seem like it's not an
insurmountable task either but I'm
telling
you the first thing you can
do a lot of folks don't like to spray
but if you can spray if you're okay with
that and kill all the grass and the
weeds that's going to weaken the root
system and make the rest of the job a
lot easier if you don't want to spray
then I would at least SC
your field or your lawn or whatever it
is scalp it so it's if the sun's hitting
it it's burning the grass and basically
killing it at that point and maybe scalp
it again if there's still anything
existing the idea being you want to
weaken those root systems as much as
possible because it's going to make your
life a lot easier for the rest of this
project so after you accomplish that
step that's when you come through with
the tiller tilling is fun it's a great
job I mean it's amazing the results the
before and after results that you can
get with a tiller there's no tool like
it it's just incredible and you think
they're just for putting and food plots
and Gardens but they're for so much more
we actually use it for our our driveway
our gravel driveway
installations you want to peel out top
soil when you're put in a driveway and
again to make that top soil easily
reusable not full of sad clumps a great
way to do that is to till it up first
right because it just makes everything
consistent and and and breaks down as
you have it sitting there in your side
pile then you can scoop out some bucket
fold and use it in different areas of
your of your property and different
projects that you have coming up instead
of having big of dirt that you're then
picking out a whole hunk of sad and have
to throw to the side that stuff's
already chopped up with the tiller so
they're great tools to have very handy
to have around and you get creative you
can find more ways to use it so again
after getting done tilling that's when
you come through with your rake do all
that final grading take it as far as you
want right I mean if it depending if
it's just a rough pasture if it's going
to be a yard you spend more or less time
on there depending on the application at
hand at that point is when you're going
to seed use that RI again to lightly
cover up the seed so it has good seed to
soil germination apply some water and
fertilizer and Away you go we are proud
to be sponsored by rimgard Solutions a
liquid Ballance weight it goes right
inside your tires completely hidden not
only is it going to help with safety
keeping those rear tires planted on the
ground it helps with loader efficiency
and traction too the benefits of rim
guard include being the heaviest
allnatural liquid ballast weight on the
market it's not going to corrode your
rims like the old calcium chloride it's
not going to freeze and it's available
at over a thousand dealers Nationwide
find the dealer near you at rimgard
solutions.com so folks there you have it
that is a video that's in response and
hopefully for you future viewers that
are out there well if you have the same
question that you email me I will be
sending you a link to this video and
hoping that it helps you now if you're
looking for any of these tools if you
need sprayers if you need tillers if you
need rakes if you need Cedars well you
can go to goodworkstractors decom we
sell and ship those tools around the
country every day of the week and if you
want to make sure you get set up with
the right tool to fit your needs just
shoot us an email give us the specifics
of your project give us your tractor
making your model we'll get you set up
so that you have everything the right
way the first time around I want to
thank you for taking time out of your
day to stop by and until next time stay
safe we'll see you
[Applause]
[Music]
soon
oh